my name is Seth manikin I am the
director of the communications forum a
jail and hi students I'm not gonna
actually say hello individually to
everyone I know in the crowd but it's
delightful to see you all and I am
thrilled to welcome Sarah Vowell here
before we start we will post video of
this online so please do not take
pictures or videos or record this while
you're here just enjoy being here and
you can relive it later if you want
serve owl is a historian author and
radio personality she's written seven is
that right non-fiction books many of
which have been New York Times
bestsellers they have covered everything
from cranky cartographers and religious
zealots to overthrown Hawaiian Queens
and presidential assassins and they seek
to explore America's past in a way that
create a framework for understanding our
modern-day values she is a contributing
editor for this American Life nope she
is not a contributing editor for this
American Life and she's written for a
whole mess of places you might recognize
her voice from violet in The Incredibles
or next year right 2018 Incredibles 2
and and I would also like to thank the
de Flores fund for humor for sponsoring
tonight's talk and and allowing us to
bring Sarah here the way this will work
is the way all confirms work Sarah and I
will talk for a while and then we will
do Q&A for a while we are also selling
books in the back and there will be a
book signing afterwards it will take
place up here I believe so
the Red Sox are losing five to two yes I
know
I apologize for that wait what
okay so how are you good to see you yeah
when was the last the last time we saw
each other was when you were a couple of
years ago feedback I guess so I wanted
to start by talking about how you got
started your your career okay we both I
just asked when Seth put me in this
water I just asked him is still water
because I once this is the story you
said you're not gonna tell me until we
yeah because I this let this be a lesson
to you if you're doing public speaking
but I used to put on a lot of events in
New York City like benefits and stuff
and one of them was where Steve Buscemi
was supposed to read a bunch of short
stories and I only provided sparkling
water in backstage and he drank a bunch
of it and he burped through the whole
evening and he kept burping through this
Tobias Wolff story I'm blaming me so I
that's why I was just checking because
you know I live and learn I feel like I
feel like if you learn if you go away
tonight having learned anything that
would be the most valuable things I
don't stay away from carbonation and
public speaking I don't want to excuse
your behavior in any way but I do feel
like at that point in his career Steve
should have known his own body well
enough he didn't right maybe he thought
that was it was it would add dramatic
effect I did okay so what was your
question
you started out writing about music
nothing I can I just say first nothing I
have known each other a long time so I
don't remember when I stopped being nice
to you but that chip this it was a long
time ago
so I want you to know that I'm generally
a nice person just not to him what go
ahead what was your question again so hi
hi
you started out writing about music true
or false
sort of I mean that's definitely I made
made part of my living doing that in the
90s I really started as a writer writing
about art visual art because that's what
I studied in school and I started
writing for my college paper about art
and then I wrote for some art magazines
right out of college and then I quickly
started writing for weekly newspapers
there's do they start out oh my god no
weekly newspapers yeah so I I wrote for
the Minneapolis City Pages the Chicago
Reader the San Francisco weekly and
eventually the Village Voice and then I
was writing about music for those places
and so did you know before you got out
of college that you wanted to be a
writer I did but I didn't know any
writers so I didn't know that that was
necessarily possible so I kept with I I
just thought I would be an art history
professor who wrote on the side and then
when I was in graduate school for art
history they made us teach freshman art
history which is what you do when you're
becoming art history professor and I did
not enjoy that experience trying to you
know talk to 18 year olds about Vermeer
and whatnot and I thought that's no way
to live a life and keep talking about it
today yeah Vermeer
yeah and and then by that point in
school I was I was kind of already out
of that I mean I was already writing my
first book which was about radio and
ready for the papers and stuff while I
was in art history graduate school so I
was just kind of I think I did art
history graduate school because I was
afraid to be an adult but I'm sure those
of you
who are in graduate school but you have
better reasons than me and probably for
some of these engineering type things I
think for those of us who you know drive
on bridges and stuff we want you to have
as much education as possible
in the liberal arts sometimes you know
you're not at risk MIT is known for many
things but it's our history graduate
program is not one of them so yeah
they're not a huge risk of a large
segment of it I mean I did learn I'd
still like I basically think I write
like an art historian in a lot of ways
because I mean the prime thing you do is
the compare and contrast you know and
that's actually how I started writing
and started thinking myself as a writer
was taking essay exams in art history
and I remember once in undergraduate
school doing an essay exam about Greek
and Etruscan art and I remember writing
my blue book and something made me laugh
and I started laughing in the middle of
this exam and I remember everyone like
looking over at me like this is not
supposed to be fun or I was I was
writing this like if she cracked out
yeah or I remember writing I was in I
went to the Netherlands to do a project
on Dutch modernism and I remember when I
write I was supposed to be finished with
my paper and my boyfriend at the time
was waiting for me to finish because
then we were going to backpack around
Europe so he's just standing there
waiting for me to finish and he's
outside the door and he hears me giggly
because I'm some something is making me
laugh about writing about red yellow and
blue paintings and he comes in and he's
kind of irked because we were supposed
to leave already but he's like wow you
sure enjoy writing those papers and that
was the moment I thought I sure do you
know so when so and also if you ever
have to write a 40 page paper about red
yellow and blue squares you can kind of
write anything you know
so what are you laughing at were you
laughing at your own quit or were you
laughing because there was some absurd I
know I think I think I was super so
there was this one guy and he was
Hungarian
and he was hanging out in college there
was this one guy he's Hungarian in the
exam room no movie on in the Dutch
modernist movement of the style okay and
his big innovation so they would some of
them were painters but some of them made
environments which were like rooms
basically and his big innovation was
there was a corner and he continued his
rectangular his rectangle of like red
yellow or blue those were the only
allowed colors across a corner and it
blew everyone's minds everything that
always calms me out the color pass the
right angle it's like he he he had the
rectangle but then it was you know it
was like the corner of a room so the
rectangle continued across the corner
and everyone just thought like what an
innovation and you know and now known as
that Hungarian yeah it was fill most
food jars totally yeah and so I can
teach this stuff I just wouldn't want
cheese not yet right so so how did you
go know how you put up with it sometimes
I mean sometimes the teenagers are I
mean maybe here they're all excited to
be here teenagers yeah but I remember at
one point when we got to the 60s and the
performance era I do remember I did this
thing where I had this huge rope this
really young rope and I don't remember
what point I was making but I tied them
all to each other this is a class you
seen as a graduate student yes I'm sorry
okay I tied the students up with a rope
and it end left one and left
and I never came back how are your
evaluations that's okay
some appreciate it it seems like you did
have a fair amount of fun teaching oh I
should try that tactic with my students
so how did you go from because your
first book was about listening to the
radio yeah so how did you go from
rectangles of color
traversing walls to listening to the
radio for a year right well I went from
writing the papers and doing the essay
exams to writing for the school paper
about art and then out of school I wrote
for a little art magazines and stuff and
and then oh I know I was I was about to
start graduate school and I was 1994 and
the Republicans took over the Congress
remember this I do and they called
themselves the ditto head caucus because
they all thought that Rush Limbaugh was
responsible for their election which was
generally true and I had never heard
Rush Limbaugh and I thought this that
radio is having this huge effect on the
country and and then as now people have
had their own listening habits and you
know like I had never listened to these
talk radio hosts and these shows most of
them still around including Rush
Limbaugh and I was Alex Jones and then
also I don't remember him
maybe maybe so I decided I should dig
into this and I just ended up keeping it
it ended up being a diary of listening
which was actually you know horrible the
book itself or the listening to that
both but I mean it's a very like young
angry persons but but also the listening
to them made me a little young anger
crazy I mean it was it was really
horrifying because I you know I was like
and I
person and they were saying some really
really murderous literally murderous
things you know I mean it was also
before Littleton this was basically the
year 1995 it was the year of like the
patriot movement became was really outed
culturally because of the Oklahoma City
bombing the first day I think I turned
on the radio and there was a kid calling
in a conservative talk show saying that
he had a paper route and this other kid
was Horning in on his paper route and
what should he do and the host advised
him to get a gun or I remember visiting
my parents in Montana and there was a
big snowstorm and and it was at night
and it was really beautiful and I dug
out my old cross-country skis and I went
cross-country skiing through the streets
and it was very beautiful and I came
back and I turned on the radio and one
of these hosts was saying that one way
to employ all the welfare mothers was to
line them up at the border and have them
gunned down all the illegal immigrants
and so we listening to that kind of
where they have have women on welfare be
responsible for murdering incoming
traffic illegal immigrants across the
southern border so like if you listen to
stuff like this every day for a year it
really gets to you or it didn't me so it
was I mean the one thing I think there
is value in just the documenting all of
that it's kind of an historical document
at this point you know and so that was
yeah that was my first book and so after
that somewhat poisonous experience but
it was like one great thing that came
out of it was there is this one guy
doing this weird local show in Chicago
where I was living and that man was Ira
Glass and he was starting this American
life and right after that I started
working for him and that was because he
read part of the book he read one it was
in the book because I I act
one of the things in the book is right
towards the end they were starting this
American life and I went and hung out
with them for a day as they were making
it and then I just kind of became
friends with him and was having dinner
with him not long after that and telling
him this one story and and he was like
oh great can I give you a microphone so
that's how that started it was during
that with that I was in the embryonic
stage when IRA was trying on his rush
limbaugh personality
yeah I mean he had this like crazy local
show called the wild room where he and
this other kind of unhinged two guy
would I mean it's an interesting there's
some interesting stuff in that book
because it's where I first heard of the
internet like and and it was when we
were neither come out I think it was it
was documenting the year 1995 right and
they were they earned they did a show
develop devoted to it this thing called
America Online and I was I just was like
what like these people are talking to
each other but not on the phone no I
mean there was a lot of stuff where it's
like it's happening when you fight first
find out about something you know right
1995 I thought the internet was more I
feel like a 95 I mean I was like kind of
I was never a forward-thinking
technologist right right put it that way
and so but I knew I mean remember this
thing with the rectangle like that's the
kind of stuff I knew about right right
so from there you and immediately
started doing things for Aaron for this
American Way yeah and were you surprised
or how did you find that experience I
mean for it seems that writing for print
or for a written medium is so different
from writing for radio yeah I mean for
one thing the great thing about radio is
you don't have to have transitions you
just like say something play some music
and then
move on to the next thing right so
that's simpler although I always feel
like that's what chapters are for which
you yeah I don't I don't have chapters
but I do have breaks right she's
basically the music of the of your books
yeah what why jumping around a little
bit but what I've always been curious
about that why because I feel like
chapters are so useful in order to give
yourself an out for a transition and
also to give readers like a sign that
they can take a break you know sort of
like recollect themselves so why do you
not have I don't care whether the reader
takes a break like they do that you know
they do that when you're not looking
where whatever like they could be in the
middle of one of your chapters I make a
ticket for a baby with a dryer button
you could like yeah and they're like oh
I got to get that stuff out of the dryer
that they're taking that break whether
you're at the end of the chapter I have
trackers in my book and I try to make
sure that that's not happening yeah I
think the chapters are why you have
tenure god you're gonna gut your
chapters but notes you're like a real
you're like a real writer right um I I
don't like chapters for me personally
because I find them kind of constraining
but also like certain information
sometimes it some like chapters tend to
have a equal weight or something and for
me
certain things are only there's like a
small thing and a big thing and then a
medium-sized thing and then another
small like you know I just like to I
like to do each discrete chunk let it be
what it is right okay
and also I I mean writing about American
history I feel like for the general
reader this is what I do and I I'm
always trying to get away from that
textbook mentality you know is that
something that you were worried about
with radio on or with
laughter that was a diary so it was just
everyday or whatever but and then there
were essay collections so that was
really was just epic
yeah that was an essay collection but so
what was your first I also just don't
want I don't want the reader to like
really stop I just want it to all be one
narrative or feel like it I don't know I
just don't like chapters for me right
okay what was your first book that was
not a collection or not a diary what was
your first sort of it was resolved
assassination vacation it was about the
assassinations of presidents Lincoln
Garfield and McKinley or as my editor
put it all the ones except the one
people care about right I feel like
people care about Lincoln yeah they do
yeah
the other two possibly not absolutely
not yeah and so that was I mean that's
it's a fairly dramatic shift from
writing sort of essay sized chunks to
writing to writing essentially a book of
history mm-hmm what what made you decide
to make that to make that shift I yeah
there was kind of when I first started
working on that radio show I would do
stories about whatever and most of them
were kind of arts related like about
songs or movies or there were personal
or personal essays and then there was
this shift when I did I made a
documentary that was an hour long where
my sister and I drove the Trail of Tears
because our family is part Cherokee and
that like really changed my life because
I hadn't never done anything like that
and I just loved the whole process
I loved the research I loved going to
the historic sites and I also felt like
[Music]
it was interesting doing the research
because it was not even though I liked
it the reading and
I found any really pleasurable reading
about the subject about the Trail of
Tears yeah it's it's a shocker yeah no
but I I mean you can write about a
bummer in a in it in a pleasant or in a
like entertaining way or a gripping way
or just a way that makes you want to
read for the heck of reading and I and I
thought I was and I also never found a
really coherent yet complicated version
of the story because it is a very
complicated story and there's a lot of
within the tribe itself some betrayals
it's not necessarily an entirely heroes
and villains kind of story
and there are a lot of intricacies and I
never found a story a version of it that
was coherent but still complicated and
that I liked enjoyed reading and I was
really proud of how we put that story
together and explain things without
dumbing it down but still being coherent
you know right um so I felt like I and
then I got all this mail from people
where they would say I didn't know about
this thank you for telling me about it
or I sat down at the kitchen table with
my children and talked about Indian
genocide and and I felt like we all had
a good way yeah I felt like it had a
purpose you know and that people had
this kind of hunger to learn about their
past in a way that maybe they didn't all
get from school so so when you say that
there were there you didn't find
anything about Trail of Tears it was
enjoyable to read do you do you mean
there wasn't like turgid and and and
dense and felt like what yeah I mean
like you know when like if you read Hana
arrant talking about the Eichmann trial
that is a gripping book about a pretty
grim subject that's what I mean I mean
there wasn't it wasn't I mean I don't
well crafted yes that's what I meant I
mean I find to like one of the pitfalls
of writing about history
is when you do the research there's so
much and you learn so much and you go to
so much trouble and expense to learn
things that are to other people not
interesting not relevant and sometimes
with any more proper historians I feel
like they're not as judicious about
leaving some of that stuff out there
like I had to go to Germany to learn
this and so you have to suffer too you
know right like when I was working on
that the assassination book the last
chapter is on the Lincoln Memorial
because it would sort of the culmination
of what Theodore Roosevelt who became
the president after McKinley was
assassinated it was kind of the
culmination of that whole generation and
what they thought Lincoln in the Civil
War was about so the last chapter was in
the Lincoln Memorial and you know it
took decades for that to get built and
in those decades there were all these
Commission's because like Washington
loves a commission and all of these
arguments about where should it be what
should it look like who should design it
and I knew the answers
like I knew about every single one of
those Commission's and read their you
know and that Traverse when I first read
it was so long and it was like all the
Commission's was Jeff your editor uh-huh
yeah but I mean I and one thing here's
another thing that I think is practical
I always read everything aloud and maybe
it does come from like starting in radio
but when you read something aloud and
that you've written a new yourselfer
board that's generally a good sign that
other people will be and I remember it
reminded me of when I was in school at
my college one of the film students his
final film it was a film of highway
signs and it was just highway signs and
I remember he he showed it and the
professor at the end was like who is
this film for other highway signs you
know
like and there's kind of that work like
I had just devoted weeks and weeks to
learning like all of the things the
Lincoln Memorial could have been and
then I realized like oh apt it just cut
this down to me you know a paragraph or
something or there's there's maybe
there's a paragraph in that Lafayette
book that I think the paragraph cost me
1,800 dollars and you would like that's
a lot of money wait where did you I
don't want to talk about it or talk
about it it's really stupid or knew some
stupidity and my fault
and my part and my friend but yeah the
paragraph is cost me eighteen hundred
dollars but you would think there is a
part of me that wanted to maybe be for
that up a little more just to make it a
little more cost-effective but it's like
nothing happened then it costs $800 and
I just have to suck it up and you know
it's you know a paragraph but I think
sometimes they're historians they
include everything because maybe that's
their goal to be exhaustive I think some
of them that's the goal but my goal is
to be interesting to be to be something
that people are like relevant or it has
to be relevant or interesting or useful
or just or maybe sometimes fascinating
like one of the things that one of the
downsides of working in radio and
especially on this American life word
that it has a very strict format and
they have a kind of very traditional
kind of cinematic structure where
stories have to go somewhere and make a
point and have an epiphany and a
conclusion and sometimes there's just
some weird thing you learn you know
that's cool
and I we always called the when I was
called those my shenanigans and I would
just like put them into a story and Ira
Glass you know I would always have these
negotiations where over the number of
yeah he would be like
to shenanigan I'm like I know isn't it
interesting I think it would be like you
just had a shenanigan 40 seconds ago you
can't have two shenanigans like okay how
do you talking about you can't have two
really interesting things side by side
but but if something has to like a story
has to be propelled forward or you know
it just touched him like moot everything
has to keep moving and and one of the
things I like about writing books is
things don't have to keep moving in that
direction you can like veer off like a
detour and you can do that in books just
by dint of any more there's more room
also I think listener readers are just
more that they're they have more
patience than listeners you know because
a listener is kind of like a dog they
seem to sit there well like a dog will
be like with you and then it's like
what's that and like you know or they're
driving or they're doing chores or a
very different cause but like a reader
you have a reader's attention and if you
lose the reader's attention she just
goes back to where she lost her train of
thought so you can keep a reader you can
go a lot more places I think with the
reader like a listener you're just
trying to like keep them with you you
know right you can't you can't go up
somewhere yeah no I need to read always
used shenanigans as false
well like if I call shenanigans on
someone that means like I don't believe
that
Oh to rethink my use of shenanigans yeah
I know it's just like a fun fun thing
right like in that brick there's a whole
section that's supposed to be about the
Battle of Brandywine but I really like
the paintings of Andrew Wyeth okay and
I'm and the Battle of Brandywine
happened in the Brandywine Valley where
Andrew Wyeth paintings paintings and so
sometimes I can I can make
I can like weld those things together
but sometimes I'm just like literally
playing hooky from researching the
Battle of Brandywine to go look at
paintings because they're interesting
and because the Battle of Brandywine is
not as interesting it's pretty
interesting right yeah yeah so but I'm
just saying like it's just something
like it happened and it's interesting
and I feel like it there's enough there
to for it to reason to be there so you
you you said that you like what you
write to be relevant or useful or
informative and the subjects that you've
chosen for your history books have been
I don't think that any of them are sort
of obvious subjects if someone's
thinking what's the most relevant or
useful or informative part of American
history like the Puritans or or a
Lafayette so and yet these are the
things that you've obviously MANET or
the overthrow of the Hawaiian monarchy
well I mean let's see I mean I was
writing about the overthrow of the
Hawaiian monarchy and how America took
over the Sandwich Islands right at a
moment where we were invading these
countries in the Middle East and
engaging in regime change
you know I'm sold you convinced me I'm
not saying there's like a there's like
an equal value of relevance but there
are overtones that generally I like for
things to somehow speak to the present
moment like the Lafayette but it started
out as it came from us you know just
writing about not his service in the
Revolutionary War but when he came back
in the 1820s and he 40,000 people
greeted him right in New York Harbor I
think it was something like 80,000 yeah
so it's like you're really people came
to greet the Beatles right and so it was
this really big deal when he came back
in the area you're nice thank you
good job and
he like it was a party every night for
13 months he went to every state and the
whole country just fell back in love
with him and it was just he was like
this article of agreement and I thought
oh that'll be nice to her work on a book
that about this guy everyone liked which
there aren't really many people in this
country that you know everyone likes and
and then I started researching it and
basically at every point in the story
whether he's a young man in the war when
he comes back in the 1820s all it is as
Americans like bickering around him and
like having these arguments and the
Continental Congress is not getting
along with the Continental Army and and
when he comes back in the 1820s it's
during the election of 1824 where there
wasn't a clear winner in the electoral
college and it was this big fight in the
House of Representatives had to pick the
president and it could have led to
violence but it didn't but so the thing
that seemed exotic about him about
writing about this person that all the
Americans agreed on as a vacation from
you know in this country we live in
where we you know can't agree on
anything it just brought me back to you
we can't agree on anything yeah and and
we and because our founders built this
country
to be that way and so when as an
argumentative
you know as like the point of this
country is that everyone has the right
to argue and say what they think believe
what they want and how like the way the
country is founded like that's how we
turned out right I mean there's
something and in in all of your books so
I find that relevant yeah I was not I'm
not all right
well yes there's something in all of
your books that is kind of optimistic
and oh really I think so yeah and in the
sense that there you have a certain in
the way that you were just talking
that's animated sense of an animating
sense of America as being a noble and
worthwhile experiment sort of runs as a
through-line even when you're talking
about times in American history when we
as a country or our leaders have not
always behaved well is it is it is that
something you come to naturally is that
something that you felt like his as you
learned more about history you sort of
came around more to that point of view I
mean I've always had a kind of split
version of the history because of who I
am and my family and you know the first
American history I learned was the Trail
of Tears so the first American history
learned was about a constitutional
failure and how the you know Jacksonian
removal policies forced my ancestors at
gunpoint to Oklahoma and so that always
shaded any gullible flag-waving
qualities I have like there's no getting
around that but I mean one of the
reasons I mean and that was because when
I was a kid there was it was like the
70s and there used to be a big fad some
of them still exist for these outdoor
amphitheater historical dramas like
there's one down south about the Roanoke
colony I think the Mormons have won and
the Cherokee Nation had one where it was
this big pageant and every summer we
would go to the Cherokee Nation capital
in Tahlequah Oklahoma and watched this
being this theater version of the Trail
of Tears and it was very theatrical but
like dance it was the only theater I
basically saw till I think I was you
know 13 or something so that was the
first history I knew I knew that I hated
Andrew Jackson before I ever heard of
George Washington so naughty before you
had heard of George Washington I mean
Andrew Jackson was the first president I
ever
heard of it's kind of like I'm if you
ever are in a conversation with an Irish
person and there's a well just bring up
Oliver Cromwell and they'll just you
know they just can't shut up it's like
one of those kind of things where it's
just your birthright yeah and so there
is that I've always had this like
there's like always going to be an
asterisk on the big American ideals
right but also I don't know like I was I
was also a kid during the Bicentennial
and 17 in um 1976 and there was their
freedom I mean around here you must all
take this for granted but there was this
thing called the Freedom Train and it
had the Declaration and the Constitution
like on a train and it went around the
country and I remember going to that and
and you're really it was like one of
those big indoctrinated years and all
the like old-fashioned American civic
stuff and I did you know laugh that
stuff up and I still do believe you know
like that idea all men are created equal
I mean I think can you think of
something more important that's been
said like I can't then all men are
created equal
yeah sure there's some edits I might
make to BC that idea you know is a
pretty sound idea right and and I
believe that and so I mean that does
enemy how I write about the history and
also and and maybe more and more Assange
and older I don't need everybody to be
perfect right I think I mean we're
you're kind of talking about this
earlier how every I don't know you were
part of the conversation yeah and this
isn't really an idea that I've fully
formed but I'm kind of
it's sort of interesting to me how
especially online and in social media
not that I'm like terribly part of that
world but there there's all this
nitpicking it everybody and people want
I guess
everyone to be these well-rounded
likable people all the time you know and
I don't really need that and like for we
were specifically talking I was reading
the oral history of Monty Python I was
going to find a way to get to that yeah
and and on the tree on the plane here
and one of the undercurrents in the
Monty Python story is that Graham
Chapman was lazy and didn't you know he
didn't do a lot of the real elbow grease
on putting the shows together Python was
Graham Chapman like he's brought he's
brought in life of Brian and he's the
gay one but he did like he would just
sit there and the other pythons would do
the work and he would just kind of be
around and he was also an alcoholic
so it's drunkle art but there's pretty
young yeah you have a cancer tall he
wasn't the tallest I don't think was he
I thought he was we can't like look that
up later but anyway what happened was
John Cleese had purchased a faulty
toaster and he he was really irked about
it and he wrote this whole long
beautifully crafted sketch about trying
to return this this toaster that didn't
work and grab Chapman who I guess always
was smoking a pipe he just you know read
it he's like yeah it's boring it needs
to be a parrot and so that's all he
contributed right to the parrot sketch
right was the idea that was a parrot
it's a it is it started out as basically
a customer complaint of jooheon's
talking about like the country and the
founders and everything sure they had
flaws you know and they weren't perfect
people and maybe they didn't
like perfect phrases but you know the
there's still value there like and I I
would hate to lose that like I I was
writing an op-ed for the times this
summer about you know there was this guy
running for president and he was picking
on these people whose kids the kid had
died in Iraq he's now the president but
at the time it's so the what happened
was the father of the slain soldier had
pulled the Constitution out of his
pocket at the Democratic National
Convention anyway I was writing this
thing about George Washington and the
founding of the country and how in this
letter I'm sure you all know it that
George Washington wrote to the synagogue
and new porch after Rhode Island was the
last state to ratify the Constitution
and one of the Jews of the synagogue
wrote Washington this letter saying
basically hurray you know about the Bill
of Rights I'm paraphrasing and
Washington writes this beautiful letter
about back about how this government but
that he and his friends are building is
not about mere toleration like every
because he's implying like tolerance
means and he says like that means one
people is putting up with another people
because now we're all equal and we can
all believe we can all believe what we
want and sit under our own vine and fig
tree and specifically that piece was
about the presidency and how the first
president who invented the presidency
was saying like he was literally making
case for what the first amendment was
about and it was about everyone is
allowed to believe what they want and I
spent a whole day arguing with the
editor who was passing on the failings
of the editorial board that I had not
mentioned that Washington owned slaves
right I was like first of all I feel
like if you're
your times opinion page you probably
know that one second of all it's like
off the top look like he had a whole
life
yes she did own say but he did some
other stuff you know right and I had to
like spend a whole day trying to figure
out like how do like bend to their will
without bending to their will but it
really survives how did you how did you
handle that well I might think what
happened was I ended the thing about
where he says everyone shall sit under
their own vine and fig tree and I said
pause here a century or two while
everyone becomes includes actually
everyone or something like that
right so I sort of alluded to it without
saying and he owned slaves right but my
point is he did own slaves but he did
some other worthwhile things and I don't
remember how we got off on that just
like oh talking about the founding like
I'm having how there is real value in
these people and what they did even if
they were imperfect and they you know
owned people right I mean we shouldn't
forget either things we shouldn't forget
they owned people but it's like when I
was writing about the Boston Puritans
which I found even people in Boston hate
them but one reason I wanted to write
over each other I mean like some of them
like - some of them like some of you -
yeah right but one of the things I why I
wanted to rescue them was because I
found the word Puritan was kind of used
as shorthand for idiot apparently
because the Salem witch trials and all
that which came later and those were
stupid but I I was like yeah they said
and did unreasonable things but they
lived before the age of reason and they
still were you know some of the most
learned bookish people of their time and
you know when they came here they were
only here for you know basically five
minutes and they
started building that other College down
the street because they didn't want
their ministers they wanted their
ministers to know Greek and Hebrew and
they needed their their clergymen to be
learned and you know a lot of them had
theology degrees from Cambridge and they
were thinkers and readers who are mainly
focused on one book but they they had
ideas and they you know handbook and
they weren't just idiots right right I
mean it is it's an interesting challenge
today and it's certainly something that
has come up a lot in the past several
years which is how do you fully take
stock of historical figures while
respecting both the realities of their
time and our time yeah I mean it is
always like that is always a pickle but
I mean I find one of the things that's
just really useful in life in general is
empathy and and it can also just be
really educational
I mean sometimes writing nonfiction
sometimes is the most basic the most
basic instinct is to just find the truth
and sometimes that there's a lot to be
learned and just trying to like get to
the facts like when I was writing about
the American takeover of Hawaii there's
still a lot of acrimony in the Hawaiian
Islands today and there's a whole
sovereignty movement in which Native
Hawaiians are still protesting the you
know overthrow of their queen in nine
1893 in the annexation of the islands by
the United States in 1898 people are
still upset about that and I understand
why but and so the the people who
engineered that were the children and
grandchildren of New England
missionaries like you know specifically
these missionaries who came from Boston
Harbor and sailed all the way to the
Sandwich Islands jhin's
you know they not just the Sanders
islands all over the world that these
New England missionaries would show up
in a place and tell people how wrong
they were and and then so those people
were actually idealistic in their way
but their children and grandchildren or
the one who started the sugar
plantations and they ended up by the end
of the 19th century white people owned
like 90% of the land there and yeah and
they're the ones who overthrew the
Hawaiian queen and and gave the islands
to the United States and so among
especially the native population there
there's still a lot of anger toward the
missionary boys as they're known and I
understand that but at some point in the
research I found the actual letter from
Boston all roads lead back here
generally where the mission HQ here in
Boston sends them this this letter I
think you know forty years into the
mission and some of these people they've
been they were born in Hawaii they've
never been anywhere else and they get
this letter saying we're cutting you off
good luck where's like and they're just
stopped they're not going to fund the
mission anymore and these people have
never lived anywhere else and they you
know it's their home and they have kids
and and they live in these islands with
a 365 day growing season so they start
being farmers and they start growing
sugar and that takes off and that the
sugar plantation just completely changed
everything they changed the politics
they change the ecology like you know
growing sugar takes a lot of water and
they change the racial makeup of the
islands because they bring in all these
workers from all over the world from
Japan the Philippines Scandinavia
Portugal and everything changes because
of these sugar plantations and every
change affects the natives negatively
but but this goes back to that letter
saying you're on your own
and these people are stuck and they got
to make
and that's how the plantations start and
it's just it's not this nefarious plan
to take over the government and take
over all the land it's it's basically
like each family deciding oh my god we
got to eat what are we gonna do and I
think that's something anyone can
identify with you know and so sometimes
all of these like big historical debates
and problems I mean everything can
always like harken back to some small
human moment okay thank you there are a
couple more things I want to ask you
about but why don't we open this up for
a little while to questions we have two
microphones if you are comfortable
please state your name so we know who
you are when you ask a question where
are the microphones there's one there
and one there
Oh half way up the stairs so if people
have questions head over to the mics and
ask and while you guys are screwing up
your courage to do that is there
something you're working on now a new
project that you have in mind I know
earlier today you went out to Walden I
think there's some I mean I don't think
it's my next book or anything but I have
been thinking about Thoreau a lot and I
yeah I did go to the pond and there
wasn't a Don Henley pilgrimage it was
the road thing he's one of those people
where I he's one of those people I
always want to stick up for because
there every so often there's some like
first like it was I mean it was just in
the New York girl like last year where
someone's just like I hate Thoreau and
you should too and I get that he's a
dented person and maybe not always a
barrel of laughs but there are a lot of
things worth admiring about him and what
he did and that place and living there
and I I mean I I'm drawn to writing
about people like I'm one of my my
favorite Puritan was
the guy who founded Rhode Island because
the Boston you know Buddha and him out
of Massachusetts Bay was Roger Williams
and I think I described him as someone
who's hard to like but easy to love you
know I think of like Thoreau in that
collection of hard to life's not so bad
yeah right
you did right it would really
transcendence yes some good sentences
and also he was a conductor on the
Underground Railroad I feel like that's
a pretty good life yeah yeah so lay off
New Yorker magazine Schultz yeah hi my
name is Pete Riley and hi the question I
have a listening to I was just thinking
that do you think you could write about
Andrew Jackson I mean I have a little
bit when I was writing about the Trail
of Tears in his part in it and one of
the things that happened on that
documentary was I went to the Hermitage
his house in Nashville and as my sister
would would tell you I probably could
have been a little better behaved when I
was there so I don't know if I have more
to say about him I mean he is
interesting to me too because even
though like I'm part Cherokee but mainly
I'm all riff raff and so for my my riff
for the riff raff side of me you know
like he's if he's the guy that makes it
possible for people like us the nobodies
to think they can become president and
you know there are things about him that
I do I can admire and you know how he
handled the Nullification Crisis and all
that and so I kind of think of myself as
a Jacksonian Democrat who hates Andrew
Jackson but I don't know if I have more
there more to say I don't know thanks so
I have gotten a little bit of revenge on
him and I'm really looking forward to
him sharing his money with Harriet
Tubman
yes yes Kenoi from high did you say from
MIT here here okay
I loved Trail of Tears and I loved your
early work on radio and I particularly
loved your remark about how people are
complex there are many assets and faces
to them
you mentioned Washington we had a little
challenge posed to you on Jackson in my
family history I think about Franklin
Roosevelt who did great things but also
Locke my parents up in prison camp
yeah the obvious are you a
japanese-american yes I am yeah
but the obvious question is that we have
a current incumbent of the Office of the
President uh-huh and I can see
problematic aspects of his character and
what he's been doing that was nicely put
yeah in 10 or 20 years when you're
writing a book looking back when you
become the historian looking upon the
current period what do you expect to be
able to say that would offset some of
the deficits that stare us squarely in
the eye Wow
no pressure
I mean one thing I do no matter what I'm
writing about is I'm there's that saying
that history is written by the winners
but it's not true it's written by the
writers and one thing I always love when
I'm delving into some something and
especially writing about American
history there are a lot of just mistakes
and bad decisions and you know that was
obviously a big one of the big ones
there's always someone who's speaking
out you know like writing about the I
mean one of them the bees in my bonnet
is always the spanish-american war and
there's and when I remember when I was
um I was writing some op eds for the
times right after we invaded Iraq and I
would write my little this is a bad idea
kind of op eds and I think like this
isn't doing anything I should just be
faxing them into the trashcan under my
desk you know but the they are part of
the record just like Henry not Henry
James what's his brother's name William
James William James are Mark Twain or
people you know arguing like we should
not be torturing the Filipinos there's
like this record there's always a record
of people who are standing up there's
always an argument there's always a
conversation and I think it's valuable
to go back and read those as like what I
could say about now I don't know I mean
it's pretty depressing I mean has anyone
been watching the Ken Burns Vietnam War
series are you finding it this is a
terrible thing to say but slightly
comforting how stupid the leadership was
throughout the war and how so much of it
is the bad decisions and you know life
and death decisions are being made
because people don't want to be
embarrassed it's all about like most of
history is the delicacy of the male ego
I find
and so or like you know there's that
Johnson he like there he's on tape
talking about how like candidate Nixon
is committing treason by going behind
his back and you know back-channeling
with the Vietnamese and there's all this
really evil evil stuff going down and it
makes me feel less alone so I mean - I
guess the thing is always just tell the
truth I mean I've been thinking about it
lately because I noticed one thing I
noticed watching
Al Gore plug his movie recently or
Tallahassee Coates has his new book out
and the interviewers when they're
interviewing them about you know the
racial situation in America or climate
change they always in like the TV
journalists like can you give me some
hope and gore does tonic house is like
nope but it's like why why do we need
like everybody to be hopeful you know
sometimes you just want the person to
say like here's the problem like there's
value in that you know so I don't see
that I'm like God wouldn't that be the
work I mean one thing that happens is
looking back is things all seem to
always get worse in some ways in terms
of public discourse like I was working
with these high school students this
past year and they were having a hard
time dealing with you know current
events and I remembered being their age
and I don't know if you remember this
when President Reagan was trying to back
like it was during the iran-contra
thing and President Reagan goes on TV
and he says so I told you no we did not
trade arms for hostages I believe that
I've heard yeah I believe that in my
heart turns out not to be true but I
believe that it's true he said something
like I believe it in my heart but the
facts say different yeah wait hand me
that I
think I like I don't have glasses here
you find it so like but I remember being
appalled as a kid like the president is
coming on to me and saying he believes
something in his heart like if I pulled
that [ __ ] in a high school term paper I
would be like that would I would get a D
right and so I just remember being like
outraged like the president is coming on
TV and saying he believed something in
his heart but he did like say the truth
he did say like it doesn't feel true but
it's actually the truth he said it was a
few months ago I told the American
people I did not trade arms for hostages
my heart and my best intentions still
tell me that's true but the facts and
evidence tell me it's not yeah so I mean
at the time I was just outraged like
what is this [ __ ] this Blake this is
the president talking like this like a
nutcase you said that you said that it
saying if all said they felt true in his
heart seemed less intellectually
rigorous than the average wham song yes
but yeah but now it's like well at least
he like faced the fact even though he
you know proceeded it with a bunch of
like fairytale talk but now I mean
that's sounding pretty good right well
it's I mean it's an interesting question
because I think that a lot of people
feel right now that things are bad in a
unique way and trying to frame that
historically certainly reading
contemporaneous accounts of Nixon you
know I think Hunter Thompson's view of
Nixon could not have been any lower but
it still seems like looking back Nixon
with several large steps ahead oh we
wouldn't give for Nixon yeah yeah that's
what I'm saying I'm saying like that's
that's what not only am I not giving you
hope I'm saying like what if 20 years
from now we look back at this nostalgic
fling
it's like winning the ante John Lewis
said that like you know the march of
history is towards progress yeah you're
saying the march of history of sorts
being I don't know I mean like I do
remember even with George W Bush during
have a good night guys I've been with
his when he was inaugurated I was there
theoretically to protest but all I did
was to stand there and cry you know
right in 2000 yeah in 2000 I was
actually there at the inauguration you
were there I was covering it okay I was
just standing there crying and but but
later in his presidency when he actually
did stuff like you know invade Iraq and
remember that whole Katrina thing and
and I was like what was I crying about I
thought he would be bad for drinking
water right like or something like now
like what would it was like it was like
a failure of my imagination that I was
crying for like oh I hope he doesn't
ruin the drinking water and the economy
and like all these people are gonna die
and so we now look back upon W with a
certain degree of nostalgia and a vision
for his commitment to human rights right
well he tortured sure there's that
asterisk he was good on aids aids in
Africa sort of but uh and also on that's
why that's why I'm for saving Arabs and
Muslims after 9/11 it was not perfect
right but the contrast with the current
administration striking yeah so that's
what I'm saying like what what if twenty
years from now we'll look back on this
and be finding things to like about it
is frightening the sort of you visiting
in Trump Tower that's my point
I mean not everything has to be
reassuring yes you have made that clear
thank you
yes hi my name is Renata um I actually
had a similar question because I thought
I found your writings very reassuring
during the Bush years actually oh thanks
and now
very depressed again actually and so I
would just like to pivot I guess away
from talking about her current president
and I'm just genuinely curious if you've
read any of Bill O'Reilly books about
various assassinations and if you have
any thoughts killing me fill in the
blank yes I am not read any of them
that's really good am i yeah I have yes
I actually have a podcast where we read
like bad books and talk about them so we
read killing Lincoln for that it it
wasn't the worst book that we've run yes
we run other Fox News ranks that were
worse but it's not have you ever picked
a book that you think this is gonna be
terrible and you're pleasantly surprised
yeah oh um like we thought Norma Roberts
would be like really trashing about it
she's really great really fun
much less depressing than Bill O'Reilly
that is that is a particular pleasure to
like I remember you know how you heard
the name Charlie Chan and it's and I
think mainly from the movies it's this
nefarious he's this nefarious character
but if you actually read all the books
what he is is he's a Chinese of Chinese
descent detective in the Honolulu Police
Department and all he does is you know
pretend to be this stereotypical sneaky
Asian yeah but but he is a like a really
smart free agent who's solving the crime
and using all the white people's
stereotypical ideas against them to get
to the truth and and it was like
pleasant to find like Oh Charlie Chan is
always the smartest guy there he's just
pretending to be a dummy because that's
how he can get his information anywho
all right well thank you yes yeah hi
so I'm James Wilson MIT CMS I'd love to
move from bubbled water towards that
sort of straight water you referenced
earlier on great I'm sorry said I'd love
to move from the bubbled water towards
that sort of straight water as you
described earlier on so Renault it's
been too bubbly for us talking about
like how shitty things are actually no
so the good news is the shittiness isn't
the bubbles in my case I'm hoping to
move towards clarity
so maybe my metaphor is poorly applied
Court tension is earlier on when you
mention the a the sort of pushing
against nitpicking and highlighted
Washington owning slaves as an example
and sort of adjacent jazz with all men
created equal not just being
rhetorically maybe a little outdated but
in the context of creation not lived you
sort of seem to be marking these as
background elements that we should sort
of read the intent as more clickable
today wait so that we can barely hear
you I don't know what you're doing over
there is this better it looks really
uncomfortable but go on we'll we'll sort
of work through it team effort so when
we were exploring the conversation about
Washington and all men created equal
those sort of contrary details
heimo be owning slaves many of the sort
of folks writing the all men created
equal narrative also owning slaves that
seems like not nitpicking to call that
out as may be centrally problematic as
an how how do you interpret the messages
when the lives seem to be so
antagonistic to the message apparently
woven I mean I think one thing about
that affects me is having studied art
history you
I think this yeah remember that the
student of our history like all you're
presented with you're studying
humanities great achievements and
they're like the MOT the most beautiful
thing
in places in the world and there are
almost always made by drunks
philanderers drug at it like I mean the
most you can hope for is a guy who just
cheats on his wife and does painting on
the side you know like all of the great
like not all of them I'm sure some of
them were okay people but mostly the
great artists are always troubling or
nefarious or like not good people
necessarily you know and but they still
make beautiful things and so I think you
just kind of get used to putting up with
the other stuff like I mean or in music
like I remember when I was a kid I
played jazz and I also had this cousin
who was a drug addict
and one of the things I would do in high
school I was like a real I had a real
truancy problem but I would always go
like skip class and go to the public
library and there was this one point
where I was really into John Coltrane
and I remember skipping class and going
to the library and reading about John
Coltrane who was you know a junkie and
like sitting there and thinking about
you know John Coltrane who had just
looked up to like crazy and then my
cousin Marty who was the bane of the
family existence because of what he put
his parents through and he was just this
really talented person and he could
never like it stay clean and it was just
this thing I mean it's still going on
honestly and but I was like super
judgmental of Marty but I and I remember
having this kind of Epiphany that you
know you could have this big problem and
whether you see it as a disease or a
character flaw it has you know I saw the
beauty in John Coltrane and that made me
like start trying to think of Marty and
more human terms and like not not just
writing Marty off as a person
well you know what I'm saying yeah you
know what I'm saying but um I totally
wrote Marty office yeah totally but like
with the these founders if they have
these flaws are like owning people is
like I it's up there with flaws but I
don't think like I mean one of the
things about being Cherokee specifically
I think that gives me maybe this
perspective on humanity is that the
Cherokee owned slaves and they brought
their slaves with them on the Trail of
Tears so it's hard to completely
identify with everything about them and
and you know give them a break on
everything because I mean if you think
it's bad to be this dispossessed Indian
walking across country at gunpoint it's
worse to be one of their slaves and
there is especially I think among a lot
of like white people to just see the
American Indians and always take their
side and always you know think they're
like the good people but the good people
who were also bad people and I don't
know like I you can't you just can't get
rid of all this stuff I can't make
Jackson Pollock you know be a better
person I can't make Jefferson not own
his slaves but that doesn't mean I can't
still like learn from certain things or
admire certain things about these people
you know I think who are people I
certainly I want to put words in your
mouth but it it's sort of how when I
read your work I think that it's very
hard to paint someone as a hero or a
villain or good or bad it's almost
always the complexity of the person so
in the same way that you acknowledge
what Washington did you also never sort
of hold him up as like George Washington
day the roads but I also don't
completely write him off or even left it
who
his teenage wife was pregnant when he
like leaves to go to America no 17 he
was 17 but she was probably like 16 and
pregnant and he still leaves her to go
toward like glory in America I mean I
don't run away from that it's still a
kind of icky thing to do it's not as bad
as I mean people know we can all agree
on that but I mean that's when I'm
talking about like with the maybe with
the the empathy and like there are those
nonfiction writers and usually their
books are like the ones that are on the
bestseller list for like weeks and weeks
and weeks they are so in love with their
subjects and I do envy that they're like
oh my god William Howard Taft like let
me give him a hug and I mean that's not
those are not the people I I can't I
don't know if I just can't be like that
like I feel like I'm I'm capable of
unconditional love but you know not
blind love but I don't I don't ever see
myself like writing some book because
like oh my god I love this guy it's like
he has some good qualities right that's
more my take generally right or even the
bad people you know all right let's do
these two if you can go up to one of
them
[Music]
the heaters use
we need to sit like nuancing
for the complex history of these people
very good sneezes woman really oh well
good all these bad things it's kind of
like we privilege the things that we did
better then
wrong we're also not talking about just
like the history of talking about art
history the different people who you're
saying it's like well there's many
reasons why these white men are going to
be able to have more are gonna be
privileged in in the knowledge in kind
of the culture production process so I
guess for me I just feel like especially
when like when you make kind of like
these quick asides I feel I feel really
uncomfortable when it's like kind of
like nervous right laughter coming from
the audience when they're like
responding to like kind of making
comments about slavery or you know is
it's I just think that just like being
conscious of like are we reading kind of
the past and just continuing the same
history of like okay where we're making
people feel uncomfortable but we're just
gonna laugh about it you know cuz like I
don't know I just mean and I think there
is a difference between like an event
like this where you know we have
whatever an hour and a half or and
versus a book like their whole sua's the
of the book where it's way more
meditative and there's like a section in
there where I'm talking about there's a
moment when the British are ready to
capitulate and they're ready to think
the war is going so badly for them that
they're ready to give the Patriots
everything they wanted before before
they before the separation and there is
a moment where I ponder like what
everyone's gonna read your book right so
like you're sitting here in an audience
and you have to just like kind of be
mindful of the fact that when like it's
kind of like at different touchpoints
like you're you're reaching different
audio and I understand like the if
you're doing your thing and it's not
necessarily a matter of like oh like I'm
criticizing but just criticizing you but
just like keep in mind that there are
gonna be people who this is gonna be
their first time like interacting with
history in this way and so like when if
it were in a public space and we're
talking about like history and like
using humor to look kind of like like I
don't know it's just it just makes me
feel really uncomfortable cuz it's like
everyone's gonna leave this space right
and then it's just we don't know how
people are gonna go and say oh it's okay
that we're like we're sugarcoating the
cat the past but I think it's really
important to be like okay we can nuance
to pass but we also need to just be very
critical and like and I just I feel
really like I don't know I just like I
feel really uncomfortable like being
someone who's a descendent of enslaved
people and it's just kind of like wow
like we can we I don't know there's just
a lot there's a lot well it sounds like
you have some things to say about this
so do do more of that but what I'm
saying is I mean do you believe that
everyone is created equal and how it
should have equal protection under the
law
feel like we're doing the same thing
over and over again and I'm like sitting
here like okay you know but
predominately white audience and like
when you make comments about like sleepy
it's just like
that's not I'm sorry I'm sorry about
that that's definitely not my intention
I mean one of the things that I'm trying
I'm trying to like fit in a bunch of
stuff
when the humors useful a bit kind of
it's just one of the things I'm not
being I don't use humor to be dismissive
one of the things I think we use humor
for is because life is painful and it's
one of the ways to deal with that but
it's also sometimes it's just a
shorthand to get to the truth it's it's
certainly like how I think like let me
try to think of an example like when we
were talking about the inauguration of
President Bush in 2000 and one of the
reasons that I went there supposedly to
protest was I was really upset with the
process of that election right because
the Supreme Court ended up choosing the
president and it was it seemed to me a
pretty fishy process and I had like a
lot of anger about that it seemed
arbitrary and unfair and but I'm a
writer so I can't just there has to be
some like artistry into the
communication of my anger and everyone
when I was writing about that experience
like everyone at the time that's all we
talked about and thought about was that
and when I was writing about going to
that inauguration because it was gonna
be for a book I still sometimes I know
like people read things years and years
and years later and I needed to somehow
communicate that it had been this big
like countrywide trauma of that election
and here's how I did it maybe maybe you
don't approve but I was trying to refer
to that when I was writing about that in
our inauguration from the moment when
President Bush finished his speech and
everyone was like walking out
and I was standing out on the mall and
looking up at the jumbotron and I was
watching them all like file out and
there was you know old President Bush
and there was President Clinton and
there was Al Gore and then I saw a Bob
Dole and and I I was I thought who I had
always like grown up loathing as a
person and of course now I would give
anything to have him running the Senate
but um I saw him walk out of the dais
and and I said like I have developed a
soft spot for a dull because he
symbolizes a simpler more innocent time
in America when you could lose the
presidential election and like not
actually become the president so instead
of like spending five pages recapping
everything that had happened that was
just like one quick way of saying of
communicating everything I felt about
that election and it's a joke and it's
like quicker and I would hope like a
more entertaining way to say oh it's
just like weeks and weeks and no one
feels good about this outcome so that's
definitely how I write and think and I
think also one of the things when I was
talking about my argument with The Times
about like not mentioning Washington
being a slave owner that wasn't about
diminishing his slave owning that was
about respecting the reader that was
about me thinking like the readers know
who this guy is and I just want to talk
about this one letter that he wrote and
I don't need to do his whole biography
every time I mention his name and that
was just about not dumbing it down for
the readers it wasn't about giving
George Washington on a pass on the worst
thing he ever did it was about
respecting the reader and their
intelligence
people reading the opinion page of the
New York Times that know that George
rush how many people have just learned
tonight that George Washington owned
slaves you just learned where are you
from England he owned slaves you should
lick look into it it was it's a terrible
pox on her country right I know because
you mainly talk about all of your
conquests around the world but that's
all I'm saying that wasn't about like
giving Washington a past that was about
about like not dumbing it down for the
reader that's all
even even though you're saying like oh
I'm assuming that very beautiful smart
but a lot of your readers arts like
great like a lot of immediately or you
have an opinion page they're pretty
smart like you keep out late white
liberals right a lot of leeway because
they're considered smart but there are a
lot of things that they don't know their
advices if you don't know about and so
it's just kind of play that's just where
I'm coming yeah but that I mean no I
it's worth talking about I mean yeah
another thing though like I find part of
like our generation is we started school
one way and then like multiculturalism
happened and there was a lot of a lot of
voices hadn't been heard a lot of
stories hadn't been told and and it was
like great getting to hear from those
people and getting other sides of the
story from like women from like
non-white men from gay people whatever
that was all good but then there was
also this like the there was this whole
period where it was like the dead white
men and just because someone was a white
guy every like they were no longer
valuable and you know they do get on our
nerves but like I thought it was really
great
recently like my favorite book is Moby
Dick I just love a Moby Dick and I there
are so many shenanigans in Moby Dick and
it's just this like so close to my heart
that book it's so strange it's just the
language of it in the descriptions and
the ideas and I was like looking I was
trying to find out I was trying to I
wanted to I want to write up something
about how all these interviewers make
certain make certain writers and
thinkers give them hope and I happened
oh I was looking at him town AHA see
coats's Twitter feed trying to like see
does he ever address like why doesn't
why why do I have to be
guy and there was just this hope part
where he was talking about how much he
loves Moby Dick and I don't know where
I'm going with this just some of it
comes from coming out of that and coming
being in academia at that time where a
lot of like babies got thrown out with
the back bathwater and so I think what I
meant to say I never got around to is
because I believe in equality and I
believe in religious freedom some of the
things that disappoint us about our
founders like is because I believe some
of the things they said it's because I
believe in what George Washington was
telling the Newport Jews about how like
tolerance is a sham
we're all equal I believe that or I do I
believe like all men are created equal
I believe that's the most important
phrase because I think it's the most
important idea and the whole history of
this country which I have devoted my
life to writing about is about like some
of us trying to there's always there are
always people who are trying to make
those things come true and even if like
the people who said those words or made
those laws didn't completely believe in
them that stuff is there and it's always
there for the people who want to claim
that heritage and who always are trying
to make those things come true and I
still think there's like there's an
inherent value in the Declaration of
Independence there's inherent value in
the letter to the Newport Senate
synagogue and the fact that these
thoughts and beliefs or communicated and
made into laws by these incredibly
imperfect people they're still value
it's like what I was talking about with
the Rho I mean
or when I was writing about the Boston
Puritans I mean my favorite sermon was
the one that your that Boston's founder
John Winthrop gives either like back in
England or on the boat the one of the
model of Christian charity where it's
this it's where we get the image of New
England as a city on a hill but at
there's the part I love is where he's
talking to his future neighbors and he
says we must be as members of the same
body and love together mourn together
suffer together as members of the same
body partly because he is a Christian
and he believes he believes in that as
an ideal but also practically because
they're coming in 1630 they're coming
ten years after the Plymouth pilgrims
and half the Plymouth pilgrims died and
he's telling them we have to be together
and be as members of the same body to
survive we have to take care of each
other if we're going to actually live in
this hellish place that we've decided to
like move to but but and and that image
is my ideal that list this idea of the
body politic and that we're all supposed
to be as members of the same body
suffering and mourning and rejoicing
together even though when he you know
when they got here and winter became the
governor and he was leading the
government anyone within the circle
within that Puritan circle they were all
you know rejoicing and mourning together
and anyone who did not agree to agree
with them got banished
some of them like winter ordered they
would have their ears cut off it's why
Rhode Island came into being all these
people who keep getting kicked out of
Massachusetts some of them with their
ears sliced off and like across the
river these people you know
Winthrop government they
hanging the Quakers on Boston Common and
so I still find a kind of spiritual
loveliness about that sermon even though
the person who wrote that sermon did
some really terrible things in the name
of protecting that community that he's
talking up so I think with them with
especially with American history it's
different I think than a lot of other
countries because they don't have this
mantle of of all of these ideals to live
up to and we do and often the people who
are the most idealistic and the best at
expressing those ideals are often the
ones who like come up short in living up
to them and it's just something that's
like over and over again true in this
country and we have to come to terms
with it but I also think even if these
people have done and said terrible evil
things they've also done and said
wonderful idealistic beautiful things
that have actually made a lot of us want
to become better people and better
citizens and so I won't completely
disregard them or their efforts and
their better angels as Lincoln would say
I think this is a conversation that we
could continue to have and should
continue to have it's a larger
conversation the constraints of the time
and when we have this room I mean we
can't actually continue it now but I
hope that we do continue the
conversation you can find me or email me
it is an important conversation and it's
one that we should have as a community
we should have as writers we should have
as people who
think about an interpreter both the past
and current events so and I have one
more thing to say about that which is
like this being a college and one of the
things I mean I was a very an Institute
sorry one of the things I mean I was a
very fiery young person and I do go to a
lot of colleges and I have one of the
reasons like I bring stuff like this up
is I remember like early on I had
written this piece about my father who
was a gunsmith and like I write about
trying to come to terms with us because
I always just hated guns and and and I
remember speaking at this one college
and the students came away really hating
that story because part of it was about
like how I hate this thing
my father is obsessed with but I still
love my father and I remember being
incredibly surprised hearing irony like
a freshman class read this piece and
they like couldn't understand like how I
could love my father if I disapproved of
the way he made a living and that has
always stuck with me as may be one of
the purposes of speaking at Institute's
and what-have-you is just talking about
like like that is one of the like
fundamentals of life is trying to come
to terms with the people you disagree
with or disapprove of but not completely
writing off their humanity okay I think
we are unfortunately out of time sorry
Frankie
but please join me in thanking Sarah
before you join me in to thanking and
Sarah Chris we have email sheet up there
okay I think we have an email sheet if
you'd like to find out about future
events such as this we have three
semester six a year give us your email
the
many times we will email you is when
there is another event there are also
books for sale up there and now you can
join me in thanking Sara and thank all
of you for coming tonight
[Applause]